good morning and thank you all for
joining me my name is Matt miles I'm
ahead of serology at idak spiral
research and this morning I'd like to
present data from a study that we did
here employing the use of dried blood
spot sampling technology for serologic
serological health monitoring of our
rodent colonies feel free please to ask
me any questions at any time I'll try
and address them as we go if you want to
save them up until the end that's fine
too we'll address them when we're done
with the seminar so as the number of
agents on our biosecurity exclusion list
has grown pretty dramatically over the
past several decades so has the
complexity of our health monitoring
programs such that our ability to
reliably detect all of these
advantageous agents really requires that
we evaluate a range of sample types not
only from Sentinel animals but also from
our colony animals and and use a mixture
of testing formats both serology and PCR
there are samples that are needed for
detection of many of the agents those
that persistently colonize infect or
infest our animals are relatively simple
to collect for example feces or caged
swabs for the detection of enteric
pathogens such as as helical vector or
peltor or caged swabs for the detection
of ectoparasites however for the
detection of a pathogen exposure where
the agent is only transiently shed for
example as occurs with mouse parvo virus
or the rota virus that infects mice or
where these in asia of the animal is
required for sample collection
or when you're needing a comprehensive
and historical perspective and of
infectious disease exposure over the
life of the animal serological testing
is really the best choice among the
various testing formats and fortunately
serum isn't as easy to collect as as
many of these other samples are so there
have been relatively recent
technological advancements in
serological testing platforms and one
such advancement is the microsphere
based multiplex system that requires as
little as 1 micro litre of undiluted
serum for evaluation against truly a
comprehensive panel of infectious agents
however the conventional blood sampling
collection that we currently use today
requires a relatively large volume of
blood really due to the logistical
constraints associated with the
downstream processing and preparation
and transport of that serum also
conventional serum samples are
relatively difficult to ship and in fact
most of the serum when it gets to the
testing laboratory actually goes unused
so we ask the question is it possible to
harmonize blood sample collection
techniques with sample volume testing
requirements and in the process make
serum collection processing and shipping
less labor-intensive and save on costs
so one technology that allows for
collection of small volumes of sample is
the dried dried blood spot sampling
technology blood spot sampling or DBS as
I will refer to it is a method for
simply collecting a single drop of whole
blood onto filter paper and once that
spot is dry it's amenable to a vast
array of analytical analytical processes
including detection of antibody
so dried blood spot sampling isn't
something that's new it was first
introduced in 1963 by Guthrie as a means
to measure of phenylalanine levels for
the diagnosis of female ketonuria and
newborns and since that time as
evidenced here by the number of
publications since 1975 - - last year
it's it's being used more and more it's
been adopted as a sampling technique for
newborn metabolic disease screening
molecular testing of infectious disease
and as well as therapeutic drug
monitoring more recently kind of been in
our realm pharmaceutical companies are
adopting DBS sampling methods for a
preclinical pharmacokinetic and toxic Oh
kinetic testing in rodents in order
really to to drastically reduce the
number of animals that are used in those
studies but as a consequence it's been
shown in in a number of studies that the
DBS sampling actually improves studied
precision and also dramatically reduces
costs associated with doing those
studies so whenever we're looking at a
new technology we ask the question does
this new technology meet or exceed the
conventional technology and how robust
is this approach there are many many
studies in the literature that you can
find comparing the correlation of assay
results using for detection of
antibodies using both serum and dried
blood spot and in this graph shown here
the investigator is simply looking at a
comparison of serum samples and those
are portrayed are noted on the y-axis
and dried blood spot samples on the
x-axis and the running them on us a
standard Eliza and looking at the
correlation between those two sample
size it's - two sample types and what
this author found was there is great for
with an R value of 0.9 6-4 seer or DBS
compared to serum in this next study and
I apologize for the small font but it's
it's a similar approach to what they
were doing in the first and what this
table shows using standard commercially
available
Eliza's for detection of antibodies to
to measles virus they compared paired
serum and DBS samples and then looked at
a total of 513 samples and and when they
compared all of the samples over the
range of infection they found a
ninety-seven point nine percent
concordance if you just look at the
samples that were taken on week two to
five after infection so after the rash
has gone away so 260 samples they had a
hundred percent concordance among those
so really really great results comparing
those two sample formats so in this next
set of graphs they're asking the
question about stability of the sample
and so in the top set of graphs again
apologize for the size of them the
investigator took multiple dried blood
spots and stored those dried blood spots
at various temperatures ranging from 4
degrees to 65 degrees and then measured
the fraction of remaining antibody in
the sample compared to the zero time
point at various time points out to 150
days and so when the samples were stored
at both 4 degrees Celsius and
essentially room temperature 23 degrees
Celsius they only saw a minimal drop in
the amount of the antibody that was
present in the sample when those samples
were stored at higher temperatures as
especially those around 57 and 65
degrees Celsius there is certainly more
of a precipitous drop in those anti
malarial antibodies in the dry blood
spot sample so in the second set of
graphs at the bottom this investigator
did essentially the same thing as the
first looking at a narrower range of
temperatures so they looked at two to
eight degrees Celsius room temperature
at 20 to 28 degrees Celsius in it at
minus 20 degrees Celsius out to 117 days
in storage and what they found was
especially at the room temperature and
storage at refrigerator temperatures of
two or two to eight degrees Celsius but
the samples DVS samples had great
stability the only time that they saw a
loss signal hepatitis cease antibody
signal was when the samples were held at
at room temperature 20 to 26 degrees and
only at that prolonged period of 117
days so to investigate the utility of
dried blood spot sample technology for
rodent health monitoring we used a two
tiered approach in our investigations in
the first approach we compared DBS to
conventional serum for detection of
antibodies to the most prevalent
infectious agents into this end groups
of mice were inoculated either by kibosh
and or dirty bedding transferred with
mouse parvo virus mouse hepatitis virus
tme the miry norovirus and mouse
rotavirus as well as a negative control
groups and then secondly to evaluate
kind of the real-world use of this
technology clinic that DBS over a
thousand DVS and paired serum samples
from mice and rats
were collected from collaborating
institutions here in North America
so in the experimental studies the
paired D BSN serum samples were
collected at two four six and twelve
weeks post infection and in the
collaborative studies they were
primarily samples from institutions
doing quarterly Sentinel monitoring so
usually the animals were you know
probably three months exposed but we had
several collaborative collaborators who
are trying to track down the source of
mhb and MPV and their facilities and so
those samples really represented a wide
range of maturation of antibody response
as well as age of the animals in DBS and
serum samples both were evaluated by the
most comprehensive MFI to panel and then
data were compared for all of those data
points for the magnitude of the MFI
signal the signal to noise ratio
correlation of the DBS and serum sample
and the stability so these these next
sets of graphs that I'm going to show
you are all set up in the same way with
the MFI signal on the y-axis and the
weeks post infection on the x-axis
there's a baseline drawn in red across
that graph to represent everything
that's below it is considered negative
and everything above it is considered
positive the DBS positive samples are
shown kind of in a maroon colored bar
and then next to that is the serum
positive samples and then the two bars
that you don't see much of anyways on
this graph and not much on the
subsequent graphs or the DBS negative
and serum negative
Barr's so on this first one when we're
look when we're looking at Mouse
norovirus for both serum and BBS syrup
conversion was detected at week to post
infection probably in retrospect we
could have gone back and looked at that
week one post infection to see if we
were detecting syrup conversion at that
time I think given the magnitude of the
MFI signal that we saw at week two we
would probably be able to detect it as
early as a week so that the on the CIN
PV and graph that you see here the
magnitude of the mean MFI signal from
the DBS was equal to or greater than
what we were seeing for serum and and
that really holds true for for most of
these time points and most of the
infectious agents that we were looking
at the sensitivity and specificity of
these assays were equivalent regardless
of the the sample type we had both DBS
and and serum provided the same
sensitivity and specificity in the
signal-to-noise ratio for the DBS was
again similar to the serum in most
regards and in fact in some instances
was actually better than what we saw
with the serum
we did the same study in rats where we
infected rats with either
KRV or our TV and looked again at the
same time points two four six and twelve
weeks post infection and as you can see
here in this graph we're seeing the this
the same exact results with
seroconversion detected as early as as
week to post infection sensitivity and
specificity were equivalent with what we
were seeing from serum the magnitude of
the the mean MFI signal from the group
from DBS was equal to or greater than
what we were seeing from the serum alone
their signals in the waist ratio again
is similar to what we saw for the serum
so what about the stability studies so
so we looked at at various we took dried
blood spots from animals that were known
to be infected groups that were known to
be infected with MPD MND TM e BN MH v
and these animals were naturally
infected and really represented a wide
range of Ages and maturity of antibody
response and we spotted those blood
spots onto cards and then held those
cards at various temperatures and then
measured the MFI signal at the time
point shown here so the first one we'll
do is as graphs see the room temperature
graph and the reason that we looked at
this primarily was to mimic what we
would see kind of in in as the sample is
taken and handled prior to shipment and
we carried this study out to 14 days
post sampling and really saw no
reduction in the MFI signal from these
individual animals so the same exact
thing again when those samples are held
at at four degrees Celsius
no loss an MFI signal or diagnostic
value of those samples and for
longer-term storage and this graph shows
out to 90 days but we're out to five
months now again when the samples are
held at minus 20 there's no loss in
signal at all during the times that
we've worked so far so what about those
samples that are being shipped and they
might experience some some high
temperature direct during shipment again
we took samples and on this graph you
see the first column of samples is serum
the second column of samples is the
dried blood spot samples held at room
temperature for 24 hours the third
column is dried blood spot samples held
at 37 degrees Celsius Celsius
essentially at 0% humidity and the last
column then is samples held at 37
degrees Celsius and 95% humidity so
again just like we saw in the previous
graphs the the MFI signal that we're
getting from the dried blood spot sample
for this particular study is the mean of
the group anyways is higher than what we
were getting for serum when those
samples are held at 37 degrees Celsius
in zero percent humidity essentially
we're getting very similar there's very
similar signals to what we were getting
both in the the dried blood spot sample
held at room temperature as well as the
serum all samples were positive however
when those samples were held at at 37
degrees in 95% humidity we lost about 25
percent of the mean MFI signal for the
group so this tells us similar to what
they showed in those human studies that
it's important if you're using BBS to
protect the sample for from high
humidity and in fact simply providing a
silica gel pack
I can pack in with the dried blood spot
samples protects them perfectly from
humidity and there's no loss of signal
when samples are held that way so in
their collaborative studies and again
these samples over a thousand paired
clinical and DBS DBS in serum samples
sent to us from collaborating
institutions across North America these
samples were shipped for the most part
in standard overnight envelopes for the
DBS and ice packs for the serum and then
we tested these samples by a
comprehensive
panel and then it looked at diagnostic
correlation of the results as well as
the the magnitude of the MFI signal and
and most of these again were quarterly
sentinel monitoring samples some of them
though were ranged in ages of the animal
as well as maturity of the antibody
response and so really this thousand
animal sampling is a broad spectrum of
sample sources and the the agents that
we detected in these in these
collaborative studies were M&V Mouse
hepatitis virus and MPD and the graphs
that I'm showing here are for M&D and
MHB and again they're set very similarly
to the graphs that I showed you
previously with the MFI signal on the
y-axis and then the groups on the on the
x-axis and and then that first column of
the top graph are the DBS samples the
negatives that are on the left and the
positives are on the right and then the
serum is next to it in that same order
and again what we're seeing is a bias
towards a higher MFI signal actually
from the DBS samples with still great
signal-to-noise ratio from from those
and the same as holding true for the
image
so this next slide that I'm going to
show you is actually a movie showing
collection of a dried blood spot sample
from the lateral saphenous vein of the
mouse and it takes about 20 seconds the
the samples for DBS can be collected
from any peripheral vein or if the
animals are being sacrificed for a
collection it's it's fun to do a cardiac
puncture with a syringe and needle and
spot the blood onto the dried blood spot
card with the syringe we've used a
lateral saphenous facial vein tail vein
in any of those samples were just fine
you
no not sure if that movie played all the
way through or not but if it did not let
me describe it to you simply had a mouse
live mouse inside have 50 ml conical
tube within cut off just for restraint
and then a punctured the lateral
saphenous vein on the leg with a needle
and allowed the blood to collect on the
surface of it the hair and then touch
the dried blood spot membrane to the the
blood spot that had formed on the skin
and allowed it to soak into the card and
it's it's really that simple it's it's
it's quick it's fast and it's and it's
easy so in summary the drug blood spot
spot technology really refines blood
collection process and substantially
reduces the volume of blood that that
you have to take in that is required for
serology so it really does a great job
in harmonizing the amount of blood that
you're collecting as well as and
shipping in in matches that matches that
with the amount of blood that that is
required for for serology testing in
your laboratory the data is shown here
as well as previous studies done that's
reported in the literature shows that
DBS samples are very stable at a variety
of temperatures but it is important to
protect those samples from from high
humidity I think probably and even if
even bigger benefit to this is that with
standard serology it takes quite a bit
of time to not only collect the sample
but the downstream processing allowing
the sample to clot separating the serum
from the clot and placing that into a
new tube as well as shipping those
samples on on ice packs in the big bulky
Styrofoam containers and that's all done
away with with the dried blood spot
simply is simply
taking the sample letting it dry on the
card for approximately an hour once it's
dried the sample is good to ship and can
be shipped in a standard overnight
envelope at room temperature again with
a desiccant pack so that's that's all I
have for the presentation we have one
question so far and the question is for
the lateral saphenous blood collection
to two drops of two drops of blood were
collected instead of just one and I
didn't see the the remaining of that
part of that question so let me just
answer it in general so so there on the
cards that we supply there is a circle
drawn on the card that really represents
a 1 centimeters square area it's not
important to fill that whole thing what
we need simply is a drop that's going to
allow us to take a 6 millimeter punch
from the card but it's important that
the dried blood spot if you look at both
sides of that membrane that the dried
blood spot appears the same on both
sides and that tells us that a
sufficient sample was given to allow it
to absorb all the way through the
membrane and will give us sufficient
material then for testing there's
another comment here that they could
only see part of that video I'm
wondering if we can start the video
again and play it let me check and see
so play the video again if you didn't
see it contact me directly and I can
send it to you or at least get you to a
link on the internet to show you that so
there's another question not sure if I
understood is one one blood drop enough
and and yes one large drop of blood so
enough to fill a six millimeter square
area that soaks all the way through the
card so if you look at at both sides of
that membrane you would have at least a
six millimeter blood spot that is
sufficient for the testing needs that we
have the next question is would you
expect the DBS to fully substitute the
role of conventional serum testing are
there any shortcomings for using BBS
there the really the only shortcoming
for DBS that we've experienced so far is
that maybe it's a misunderstanding of
how much blood we need sometimes
especially people that are taking a tail
vein bleed will kind of spread the blood
over the surface of the card and and it
will be a 1 centimeter blood spot on one
side of the card but there wasn't
sufficient amount of blood placed on the
card to allow it to soak through and so
we we didn't get sufficient volume of
sample for testing for when that's done
other than that DBS yes can fully
substitute conventional serum for
serological testing not only can we do
MFI testing with DBS we can do any of
the confirmatory testing that we need to
do either IFA or Western blot there has
been a related question coming from from
people who use dried blood spot
technology who have adopted that
technology and that is if I want to take
sample to bank and keep here for myself
how do I do that
and what I've recommended for them is
that they when they request cards from
us and we do provide those cards opti
spot cards free of charge if you request
twice the number that you're actually
going to be using and you spot blood
onto one card to send us and splott
blood on a second card let that dry
stick it in a plastic bag with the
silica gel desiccant and and throw it in
your - 20 - hold in case you want to do
follow-up testing or something along
those lines they also the the amount of
samples that we get is sufficient the
amount of antibody that's eluded from
the dried blood spot is sufficient for
us to bank and we do bank those samples
for a minimum of three months the next
question is would you still encourage
institutions to do conventional serum
testing versus DBS if stuck there so in
what instances do you recommend
conventional testing over serum
I actually I again think that dried
blood spot technology works every bit as
well as conventional serum the the only
instance that that I can see needing
serum is if we got some spurious results
on the DBS which frankly hasn't happened
and you're you're wanting to follow up
with with traditional serology and see
if the results are are changed but in
short I think BBS can can fully replace
conventional serum
well it looks like that's all of the
questions if you've got if you've got
additional questions please feel free to
contact me directly and you can simply
go to our website at idec's bio research
comm and click on the button for lab
animal testing and if you if you go into
the contact file you can and find my
email address as well as my office phone
number directly and in contact me that
way so please feel free to send me
additional questions if you if you've
got them I've got one more question here
the question is what is the optimal
container that we recommend and in
shipment for so it's it's basically
related to shipment again you know we've
received we started that the dried blood
spot technology as an offering to two
clients back in July of last year and
and really have received samples from
all over the world and those samples are
typically shipped in an overnighter or
secondary shipping envelopes and the
samples have the dried blood spot
samples have never failed as long as we
got adequate volume of dry blood spot to
evaluate and so I think a standard
overnight envelope is fine so typically
we get those within it within a day
after you've shipped them we've gotten
actually some people shipping dried
blood spot through standard mail so
three to four days again based on the
IgG assays that we run concurrently with
the with the MFIs the IgG levels are are
sufficient for reliably detecting
antibodies to any of the infectious
diseases that
working at there's one more question on
hot summer days do we need any special
precaution when sending DBS strips again
based on our studies as well as the
studies that have been done for
detecting antibodies in in human serum I
think that the number one issue is
protecting those cards from moisture so
so you get them completely dry you can
dry them for an hour on the bench top or
if you've got a laminar flow hood even
better you can set them in there so that
they dry quicker package them up into a
moisture resistant bag and include
desiccant with it and ship them in in an
overnight shipping container just an
envelope I don't think in our hands that
have haven't been any additional
precautions taken or needed it looks
like all of the questions again feel
free to contact me directly by phone or
by email and I will be happy to answer
any follow-up questions that you may
have thank you